welcome to another video my beloved
weaves today we're going to talk about
bloodsy the last dark a movie certainly
not made for people with frail hearts so
without any further ado let's get right
into it the movie starts with the scene
of a train in a subway with many people
on board we see a cute girl with glasses
leaning against the wall of the train
then the focus shifts on a man drenched
with sweat who suddenly goes berserk by
transforming into a monster type
creature the man attacks a nearby lady
and devours her the people rushed
towards the other compartment of the
train to escape from the horror and most
people managed to escape from him but a
quiet girl didn't move an inch from her
position we get a glimpse of her and
she's none other than our protagonist
sire the monster stares at her but she
attacks him swiftly and he runs to the
other block of the train she chases
after him the monster takes the cute
girl from before as a hostage and flees
the train on the other hand some
teenagers in the car turn out to be
spies following the monster the monster
took the girl to a tower and then to a
park he was going to devour the girl but
sire rushes and performs a high jump
over the wall spectacularly killing him
just after killing him police and
security departments reached the venue
with a helicopter the light from the
helicopter falls on sire revealing her
beauty the teenagers from before
rescuing them and escaped from the
police with the help of their comrades
over the phone the guy asked her how she
killed the elder ben to which sire
squeezed his cheeks asking how he knew
about them they were interrupted by a
call from their hq the person on call
addresses sire and asks her if she would
like to kill fumito to which she was
surprised the guys take her to their
base the scene shifts to a building
where fumito is drinking a beer he's
visited by secretary and fumito tells
her that she will soon become the
governor of tokyo after him meanwhile
gutto fumito's task force leader comes
and tells him about the witnesses to
which he becomes overjoyed as sire is
finally there upon reaching the base
saya washed her face and a secretary
took her to the leader of the base the
leader introduces himself as guronto
upon asking he tells her that he knows
about her since the incident in okishima
an experiment took place there that
killed all the residents he also tells
her about the two organizations of
fumito that were tower in seventh heaven
she ends up joining konodo's
organization as he told her that he also
wants to kill fumito the team members of
syria are introduced the rescued girl
mana the driver of the car the hakka guy
in the car another short girl who's also
a hacker and provided an escape route to
them mana takes sire to a room on the
other hand the driver debates with other
team members about his doubts over their
new team member in the morning saya goes
to a mysterious shop with mana there she
asks for a new katana as her previous
one was destroyed in the killing of an
elder band they left the shop and began
walking towards their base they're
stopped by watchers from the youth
protection act that forbids underage
teenagers to walk around after 9 pm cyan
knocks out the watchers with a sword and
flees with mana after reaching the base
the members worry over the fact that
their identity may have been exposed to
which mana tells them that the watchers
were only suspicious of sire gurudo
takes sire to a locked chamber while
talking about the pack between humans
and elder benz the pact allowed elder
bands to eat a certain amount of people
in exchange for powers he tells her that
fumito and he are members of a clan that
performed the covenant for generations
his family mogari was tasked with hiding
the covenant from the public while the
fumito family nana hara was tasked with
the protection of mogari by using their
magic arts together they were known by
the name tower however fumito broke the
rules as he wanted to control the full
power of the covenant and for this
purpose he killed guronto's mother and
father he again asks her to kill fumito
for him next we see her taking a bath
with mana she tried to hold a
conversation with her but it was all in
vain the next day the hakka girl
discovers a lead that fumito is going to
appear for a speech in high school since
mana was a student at the high school
she easily went in with sire disguised
as a disabled student on the other hand
the rest of the team remain outside the
school as backups upon reaching the
auditorium fumito made an appearance on
the stage saya got filled with anger
just by looking at him suddenly the bell
starts ringing and the auditorium was
evacuated except for sire and mana her
eyes turned red and she took out her
katana from her crutches in anger she
dashed towards him and landed a solid
slash on him only to get disappointed as
the person was just a dummy made with
magic while agonizing she witnesses a
powerful elder band falling from the
roof the elder band attacked her with
his long flexible tentacles syed dodged
his attack and even cut a few of his
tentacles by using her katana he
attacked mana but sire stepped in and
her hand got heavily injured she managed
to slay his face but he was still alive
she gathered her remaining strength and
went for the final slash she tore the
elder ben apart they were also going to
escape but the main door was locked with
heavy security also fumito's task force
leader emerged from the smoke and
attacked sire mana begins unlocking the
door through her phone while saya
struggles with kuto just when she was on
the verge of being killed by kuuto the
rest of the team barged in to save them
they managed to escape without any major
damage the team agonizes over the fact
that they got tricked into the plan of
fumito the hakka girl was feeling very
sad as she was the one who provided the
information guru took the responsibility
for the incident as he confirmed the
operation although saya was gravely
injured she refused to get any kind of
treatment mana chases after her because
she's the one most worried about her she
tripped and ended up falling on sire her
tears begin to fall on sire's face she
shows her wounds that are healing on
their own to assure her that she's all
right mana begins telling her about his
parents her mother died when she was
young her father worked very hard in
raising her he was a newspaper reporter
with great values he was working on an
article about 7th heaven although the
project was rejected by the higher-ups
he didn't want to stop working on it
mana being confident of her skills used
the internet and hacking skills to hack
into the 7th heaven server she got some
information about the employees that
disappeared right after working in
seventh heaven her father praised her
and decided to meet fumito for answers
mana begins crying as telling this as
it's been a year since her dad went out
and there's no news about him she
trembled over the fact that he may not
exist anymore she explains that she came
to syrith to find the whereabouts of her
father but she stopped using her hacking
skills because of the fear sire holds
her hand to console her mana asked her
about her parents to which she said she
had none mana got courage in her words
and decided to confront her past the
next morning the team members were
talking about the high school incident
when they get interrupted by mana and
sire the group was happy to see both of
them in good health mana meets gurondo
and tells them she's resuming her duty
as a hacker as she won't run away from
the truth he tells the team that they
must navigate the location of the tower
before fumito discovers their base their
only way is to locate the tower and
neutralize fumito as soon as possible we
see saya standing in the backyard with
gurondo who asks her about her
mesmerizing persona she says that it's
nothing intentional saya walks back into
the mansion and finds her school uniform
washed by none other than mana she
entered the main hall of the mansion
where everyone was sleeping because of
overwork except mana saya gives her some
coffee mana tells her to drink some as
good and made it for everyone she drinks
it and while drinking mana discovers the
location of the tower thanks to her
overwhelming hacking skills she shows
the location to everyone it was hidden
with fake images but she decoded them
really easily the team immediately sets
out for their final operation mana
insists on going with sire but she tells
her to stay behind with the rest of the
team as the guards are heavily armed in
the tower upon entering the tower she's
attacked by numerous soldiers she dodges
them brilliantly making her way to the
top floor as fumito is hiding up there
she's stopped again by kuto who makes an
entrance with a blast she attacks him in
rage severing one of his arms he
activates a relic by using his blood and
transforms into a powerful elder bearing
mana gives her coordinates to escape
from him she reaches a hole that leads
to the command center while jumping she
was again attacked by kuto but saya
managed to fend him off she came across
an underground facility where strange
experiment materials and blood were
filled in various capsules sire reaches
a big door engraved with a demon lord
statue the door opens sire goes in and
finds fumito sitting on a sofa sire
begins to experience some sort of mental
exhaustion and falls on the floor on the
other hand mana and the other guys tried
to connect with her but it was all in
vain shockingly guranto is seen entering
the room the tragic truth surfaced that
kuranto was cooperating with fumito from
the very beginning he formed cyrid to
control the internet information about
tower he makes the drug only effective
desire in the coffee that she drank the
night before the drug caused her to
collapse guronto picks up a katana while
telling her that he'd never lied to the
members of syrit he only used them as
pawns this confession angered sire very
much but she couldn't do anything as she
was under the effect of the drug
surprisingly kuroto stabs fumito with
the katana revealing his pathetic and
greedy nature fumito attacks him with
sire's blood a reaction began to happen
in kuroto's body as soon as he got in
contact with the blood fumito explained
that the heads of the murgari clan keep
the covenant key in their body to
protect it and sire's blood can cause
the covenant to corrupt moreover science
blood is the only thing that can destroy
the connection between elder bands and
humans guroto ends up turning into an
eye-like creature fumito tells that he
experimented on countless people to
create more people like saya he tells
the tragic truth about mana's father her
father became a guinea pig for his
experiment and he was the elder band
that saya killed right after coming to
tokyo upon hearing this she goes berserk
fumito turns into a giant powerful elder
bearing with medusa-like hair sire
fights with it bravely she kills the bat
like creatures released by elder ben and
goes straight for its core in its mouth
she manages to destroy the core leading
to the disappearance of the elder bear
finally saya confronts fumito he
embraces sire telling her that he always
wanted to become like her after
confessing his feelings fumito turns to
dust leaving sire all alone her friends
wanted to help her but couldn't do
anything as the whole area got sealed by
the police one and a half years later
the youth protection act was finally
banned leading to a more prosperous era
mana and the other guys are shown living
happily mana still believes that one day
they'll meet sire again
mana shares a post on the internet
hoping to find sire as she continues to
look through the window the scene
changes to a thin street that shows us a
glimpse of a girl walking with a katana
on her back we presume it's sire and so
there the movie ends
what did you think of that have you
watched this movie or the tv series or
are you planning on watching them don't
forget to share your thoughts well then
see you in the next video